Well, if this is my image and these are the pixels on the boundary,
I've assigned 1 thread per element or 1 thread per pixel.
A warp somewhere in the center of the image is not going to have any divergence.
And similarly, a warp along the top or bottom rows is also not going to have any divergence
because in this case all of the threads responsible for the pixels along this row
are going to call that special boundary handling code.
So it's really only warps like these that are at the beginning or end of a row,
of an interior row, that have any divergence.
In this case 1 thread will execute the boundary code.
That's the one responsible for the pixel in the boundary.
The rest of the threads will execute the mainline code, the interior code.
So in all these cases you have 2-way divergence, and that's the answer to our question.